Alec Burdock convicted after he
testified in his own defense yeah the
Fifth Amendment exists for a very good
reason and district attorney scowl will
explain why as the trial Drew to a close
Los Angeles area double murder expert
O.J Simpson predicted that the Ella
Murdoch jury would acquit the Lowcountry
lawyer of double murder it turns out
that Simpson's powers of prognostication
don't really work for murders he wasn't
directly involved in wouldn't surprise
me in the least if this guy beats this
case the juice was wise enough not to
testify in his own criminal trial
whereas Murdoch thought that testifying
in his own defense might lead to an
acquittal
easy to see how he made that mistake
Murdoch men have been amongst the most
prominent lawyers in Hampton County
South Carolina for nearly 100 years
so before I explain why the Murdoch Hail
Mary play didn't work let's dig into the
background of this disturbing case
because it is truly Bonkers lawyers from
the Murdoch family held the solicitor
position in South Carolina's 14th
judicial circuit for 87 years in South
Carolina a solicitor is a elected
official who serves as the chief
prosecutor for a Judicial District a
Judicial District usually covers
multiple counties it's basically a
district attorney but with a seersucker
suit and a Southern drawl Randolph
Murdoch senior was elected solicitor in
1920 and served until he was killed by a
freight train in 1940. now some people
suspected that the freight train
incident was a suicide because no one
could figure out why Randolph's car
stalled on the tracks but Murdoch senior
was succeeded by his son Randolph
Murdoch Jr known as Buster who held the
position for 46 years from 1940 to 1986.
during Buster's Long tenure the Murdoch
family's private Law Firm flourished in
the small town of Hampton population
2000 because of a unique South Carolina
law that allowed people to file lawsuits
against the railroad in any county in
the state
the Murdoch firm is referred to as the
house that CSX built because they won so
much money suing the railroads Buster
was known as a win at all cost
prosecutor the South Carolina Supreme
Court reprimanded Buster several times
for improper jury arguments during death
penalty cases on two separate occasions
20 years apart he told jurors that if
they didn't impose the death penalty on
a criminal defendant he would use his
power as solicitor to release other
rapists into the community
Yes you heard that right it's hard to
imagine a worse thing a prosecutor could
say in court but I'm sure prosecutors
have it's fair to assume that the
citizens of the 14th judicial circuit
just might be intimidated by a man who
threatened to turn rapists Loose as
Revenge when Buster was done Buster's
son Randolph Murdoch III was elected
slicer and served until 2005.
now we've come full circle Alex Murdoch
the now convicted murderer is Randolph
the third's son
Alex Murdoch worked in the family law
firm and also volunteered as an
assistant solicitor Alex continued his
work with the solicitor's office until
he himself was indicted for stealing
from his clients and partners in 2022
yeah we're gonna get there so here's a
question Arthur Murdoch's corrupt well
there are open investigations into two
separate suspicious deaths that are
linked to the family in 2015 a high
school student Stephen Smith was found
dead in the middle of a Hampton County
Road there were no tire marks or debris
that would suggest a vehicle crash at
least one Highway Patrol investigator
and the County coroner ruled the death
of homicide suggesting that the body was
dumped on the road a pathologist however
concluded that Smith was likely struck
by a passing vehicle side mirror
Alex's oldest son Buster named for his
grandfather is mentioned dozens of times
in the 2015 investigation reports rumors
swirled locally that buster had been in
a relationship with Smith Alex and his
brother Randy visited the scene and were
seen going right through crime scene
tape the South Carolina state law
enforcement division reopened the
investigation into Smith's death after
officers found new evidence during their
recent investigations into Alex Murdoch
Steven Smith was killed on Sandy Run
Road back in July of 2015. investigators
say his death was originally listed as a
result of a hit and run but his mother
has many questions about that ruling now
the South Carolina Department of Law
Enforcement tells wsav that information
from the Murdoch investigation has led
them to reopen Smith's case they would
not say what evidence led to that
decision or whether the Murdoch family
was involved in any way the second
investigation in 2018 Alex's housekeeper
Gloria Satterfield allegedly tripped
over Alex's dogs and fell down the steps
of the Murdoch family's hunting lodge
Alex was the only witness after she died
from her injuries Alex told
satterfield's Sons to sue him for
insurance money Murdoch referred the
sons to his college roommate lawyer
Corey Fleming Murdoch and Fleming
collaborated on the insurance settlement
but never told the brothers that they
had in fact collected on two settlements
one for more than five hundred thousand
dollars and another for 3.8 million
Murdoch knew that one of the brothers
Brian was mentally impaired and living
on an annual salary of fourteen thousand
dollars yet he watched as a bank
foreclosed on Brian's trailer knowing
that a check from Lloyd's of London had
already been deposited into Alex's own
bank account Murdoch later admitted to
stealing over four million dollars from
the satterfields when a reporter
uncovered the Satterfield settlement
investigators started looking for other
irregularities they found that Murdoch
was ripping clients off left and right
Alex Murdoch's Empire of Lies started to
unravel in 2019. Alex and his wife
Maggie had two sons Paul and Buster on
the night of February 23 2019 Paul
Murdoch and his five friends spent the
night partying on Paul's Boat all six of
them were underage Paul's friends called
him Timmy when he was drunk because he
seemed to have a vicious Alter Ego when
he was wasted
Witnesses say that Paul drove the boat
for most of the night except for a few
minutes when Connor Cook had to take
over because Paul was arguing with his
girlfriend Megan Dowdy Paul's friends
say he assaulted Megan the boat later
crashed into a piling and they were all
thrown from the boat
everyone survived except for one Mallory
Beach who's found dead a week later
after the crash Alex visited Connor Cook
in the hospital
Alex tried to convince Conor that Conor
had been driving the boat not Paul
Randolph Murdoch III the former
solicitor arrived at the hospital and
stopped police from questioning his
grandson
Alex and his wife Maggie traips through
the crime scene eventually Paul is
charged with two counts of boating Under
the Influence with great bodily injury
and one count of boating Under the
Influence causing death
Paul Murdoch pleaded not guilty and
hired a state senator who served on the
Judiciary Committee to prepare his
defense but Paul never stood trial
because he was murdered alongside his
mother on June 7th 2021. June 7th was
the date when many things in Alex
Murdoch's life came to a head Genie
seckinger the Chief Financial Officer at
Murdoch's Law Firm confronted him about
money that she believed he had stolen
from The Firm during the conversation
Alex received a phone call that his
father's Health had taken a turn for the
worse and that he was dying in a
savannah Hospital
second or stopped her questions so he
could go deal with his father but a
short time later she realized Alex
remained in the office that check never
even came through our books he stole it
and endorsed it and put it in his Bank
of America account and we found a copy
of it on his desk he asked her about his
401k balances which he was worried about
producing in the beach family's wrongful
death lawsuit a hearing was scheduled in
that lawsuit that could have compelled
discovery of Alex's assets the beach
family's lawyer said he planned to sue
Alex and Maggie personally because they
allegedly kept a beer refrigerator at
the hunting lodge and underage kids were
free to drink up
given the scale of Alex's Financial
crimes discovery of his assets would
have revealed years of Murdoch's
criminality later that same night Alex
allegedly found Paul and Maggie dead
outside the kennels at the Murdoch's
sprawling hunting estate Alex called
9-1-1 shortly after 10 o'clock P.M
he told police that he had just returned
home after spending most of the evening
out police concluded that Paul had been
shot at close range twice with a shotgun
and Maggie had been shot with a
semi-automatic rifle the murder weapons
have never been recovered a Firearms
expert said casings found near Maggie's
body were from a rifle round called 300
Blackout after the murders Alex told his
law partners that he screwed up and
would pay back some of the money he had
stolen but by September 3rd The Firm had
found more financial irregularities
later that same day the partners
confronted Alex and he agreed to resign
the partners including Alex's brother
Randy agreed to wait until September 6th
to announce the resignation
but the next day on September 4th Alex's
friend Chris Wilson confronted him as
well see Alex
ode Wilson two hundred thousand dollars
after lying to him about a legal
settlement so Alex admitted to stealing
from Chris and blamed his behavior on an
opioid addiction and then hours later
that same day after that conversation
with Chris Alex was
shot in the head yes
seriously does this seem like a
far-fetched Netflix series yet on
September 4th Alex Murdoch called 9-1-1
and reported that while he was pulled
over on the side of a road with a flat
tire someone had shot him I stop I got a
flat tire and I stopped and somebody
stopped to help me
and when I turned my back they tried to
shoot me
oh okay were you shot yes but I mean I'm
okay Alex later admitted that he hired
his cousin Eddie to shoot him so Alex's
remaining son Buster could collect on a
10 million dollar life insurance policy
but apparently Cousin Eddie wasn't up to
the job because the gunshot wound was
just a graze that temporarily blinded
Alex Eddie would also turn out to be
Alex's oxycodone dealer Alex later
admitted that he stole from his law
partners and clients to fund his
addiction to painkillers according to
Alex on some days he was taking up to 60
Oxycodone pills so here's the House of
Cards the prosecutors were trying to
knock down a very influential family
headed by a man with an insatiable
appetite for pills the double murder of
Maggie and Paul who were mowed down on
Murdoch family property the suicide For
Hire insurance fraud scheme and oh yeah
how could we forget 99 additional
charges by the state attorney general
for embezzlement money laundering and
tax fraud first was the trial for the
murders of Poland
the trial was fittingly in South
Carolina's 14th judicial circuit the
very same circuit for which his family
had supplied three generations of
solicitors
the prosecution really wanted to use the
suicide For Hire plot to demonstrate
that Alex had a propensity for violent
schemes as the prosecutor said when the
hounds are at the door when Hannibal is
at the gates for Alex Murdoch violence
happens
the judge initially ruled that this
incident was off limits for the criminal
trial however during the trial the
defense asked a witness about whether it
was possible that drug gangs killed Paul
and Maggie the judge then reversed
himself ruling that the questions opened
the door to prosecutors introducing
evidence about Alex and Cousin Eddie
since Alex was admittedly associated
with a drug dealer the trial's biggest
bombshell was an unsent Snapchat video
recovered from Paul's phone Alex told
police he had last seen his son and wife
90 minutes before he found their bodies
he said Maggie and Paul were down at the
kennels checking on the dogs so he took
a nap watched TV then called and left
Maggie a message saying he was going to
go check on his mother Alex visited his
mother and then arrived at the kennels
around 10 where he found them dead
he repeatedly denied being at the
kennels before he found the bodies as it
turns out Paul filmed a Snapchat video
just minutes before he was killed
showing a Labrador Retriever wagging its
tail
he apparently intended to send a video
to his friend Rogan Gibson whose
chocolate lab was staying at the Murdoch
Kennels
several witnesses testified that they
could hear Alex's voice in the
background of the video
did the Snapchat video influence Alex's
decision to testify on his own behalf
almost certainly yes the very first
thing Alex did on the witness stand was
fess up that he lied about being at the
kennels Alex admitted it was his voice
on the video were you in fact at the
kennels at 8 44 pm on the night Maggie
and Paul were murdered I was did you lie
to sled agent Owen and Deputy Laura
Rutland on the night of June 7th I did
lie to them and I'm so sorry that I did
other than lying to them about going to
the kennel I was very Cooperative in
every aspect of this investigation very
Cooperative except for maybe the most
important fact of all that you were at
the murder scene with the victims just
minutes before they died prosecutor
Waters said
uh oh this admission was just the tip of
the iceberg that Alex was about to hit
in every criminal trial the defendant
has a constitutional right to testify or
to remain silent the right to remain
silent during a criminal trial means
that the jury is legally prohibited from
taking a defendant's choice not to
testify into account when deciding his
or her guilt the prosecution can't refer
to the defendant's decision not to
testify as an indicator of guilt
testifying allows the defendant to tell
his own story but he doesn't get to do
it unmediated when a defendant chooses
to testify the prosecutor gets to
cross-examine that defendant it is
rarely a comfortable experience for the
defendant and prosecutors love it
a defendant's testimony opens the door
to impeachment impeachment is just
attacking someone's credibility
impeachment can happen in a lot of ways
for example being biased or prior and
consistent statements in past criminal
convictions when a person doesn't have a
criminal record to worry about or hasn't
made any inconsistent statements then
testifying could be a safer proposition
emphasis on the could be because it's
not easy to face cross-examination under
any circumstances even a defendant with
no skeletons in the closet can be
tripped up we've seen some high profile
defendants decide to testify in their
own defense to mixed results
self-defense cases often lend themselves
to a defendant's testimony in those
cases there has to be some evidence that
the defendant perceived imminent danger
of physical injury and sometimes it can
be hard to show that without the
defendant's testimony Kyle Rittenhouse
testified that under the circumstances
as he perceived them he didn't have a
choice other than to use the amount of
force that he did Rittenhouse stood up
fairly well under cross-examination and
at just 18 years old he really didn't
have much in the way of a criminal
history or other impeachable matters in
contrast Elizabeth Holmes was on trial
for defrauding patients doctors and
investors by lying to them about
theranos's techno biology and business
relationships the subject of her trial
was whether she spent years knowingly
making false claims
Holmes had already given testimony under
oath in civil suits and government
investigations which made testifying a
dicier proposition
during her criminal trial she blamed
other people and claimed that her lies
were just misunderstandings when she
said she couldn't remember the details
of a certain topic the prosecutor
essentially impeached her with testimony
that she had previously given to the SEC
where she certainly did remember and the
jury of course convicted her so back to
Alex Murdoch he's a lawyer with
experience Prosecuting and defending
criminal cases and also probably a
narcissist so it's not surprising that
he thought he could handle himself on
the witness stand however a defendant's
credibility is absolutely crucial which
is why prosecutors try so hard to
impeach
if the jury thinks the defendant is a
liar things go south quickly and it
seems like that's exactly what happened
to Alex Alex claimed that he told one
Whopper about his Alibi that he wasn't
at the kennels before the murders but
other than that he was cooperative with
investigators and truthful in his
testimony but prosecutor Creighton
Waters was able to show a pattern of
duplicity
quote the second you're confronted with
facts you can't deny you immediately
come up with a new lie he said
the prosecutor was able to call out
numerous Lies by Murdoch for example
when Murdoch's planned to get murdered
by Cousin Eddie failed he quickly
created an elaborate story while he was
recovering in the hospital he brought in
a sketch artist to create a fake picture
of the non-existent stranger who
allegedly shot him when Alex's brother
Randy overheard Alex trying to bribe a
nurse to let him use her phone he
thought it was suspicious and brother
Randy called the police and the story
began to unravel with a sled sketch
artist
and spent a period of time with her
going forward and creating an image of
the supposed assailant
I did sit down with a I was in the
hospital and they came in sat down with
me asked me a bunch of questions I
answered their questions and yes you did
you sat there hey it came up with a
composite yes sir sat there and answered
their questions just as effortlessly and
convincingly as you've been trying to do
for the past two days isn't that correct
no sir that's that's not true the
prosecutor also showed that Alex would
say whatever was necessary to help his
own case Alex told the jury that when he
found the bodies he didn't check their
pulses before calling 9-1-1 because
there wasn't enough time but in an
earlier statement to police Alex claimed
that when he found his family murdered
he'd check their pulses and then dialed
9-1-1 the prosecutor's reconstruction of
the timeline revealed that only 20
seconds passed between the time Murdoch
parked his car at the kennels and when
he called 9-1-1
so as soon as Alex was confronted with
the seemingly impossible timeline he
came up with a new new story the
prosecutor asked Alex if he killed his
wife and child when asked if he knew who
did it Alex also said no but in an
earlier interview with investigators
Alex had actually implicated his
groundskeeper he also told the jury that
someone angry about the death of Mallory
Beach committed the murders these
inconsistencies undermined Alex's
credibility then there's the mess with
Alex's Financial crimes the prosecution
argued that Alex's Financial crimes
couldn't be separated from the murders
because exposure of his vast Financial
crimes was one of the motives for
killing Maggie and Paul
the defense countered that the financial
crimes had nothing to do with murders
and that the prosecution lacked proof
that the two were related in any way
during direct examination Alex explained
that he committed a lot of financial
crimes because of his drug addiction
Alex's lawyers portrayed the admission
of wrongdoing as a willingness to come
clean they argued that a person who
admits to lying isn't necessarily A
person who commits violence which is
true in a general sense however was it a
good strategy in this particular case to
admit to years of financial fraud
not really on cross-examination the
prosecution scored several key points
prosecutor Waters held up a stack of
papers relating to clients whom Alex
stole from quote every single one of
these you had to sit down and look
someone in the eye and convince them
that you were on their side when you
were not correct do you remember it even
one of them
if you ask me questions but I can't
I can't remember sitting down with d
Alex's response what I admit is I misled
them I did wrong and that I stole their
money what prosecutor Waters was getting
at was this ladies and gentlemen of the
jury Alex Murdoch is sitting there and
looking at you in the eye trying to
convince you of something but you
shouldn't believe him just look at how
he lied in the past moreover Alex
testified that all of his financial bad
Deeds were caused by his drug habit
which was costing him as much as sixty
thousand dollars a week who put this
thing together me that's who but
maintaining his drug habit and hiding
his financial crimes could have
motivated him to violence especially
since he already admitted to a suicide
For Hire plot to funnel money to a
surviving son finally Alex has now
confessed to several of the 99 indicted
Financial crimes he's accused of
stealing about 8.8 million dollars
including embezzling about 3.7 million
in 2019 alone if he hadn't testified all
of his financial fraud ripping off
disabled clients stealing money from a
dead housekeeper's Sons wouldn't have
been front and center in this case after
both sides rested it was the jury's turn
to deliberate and to be fair there were
weaknesses on both sides the prosecution
didn't find the two murder weapons they
didn't have any direct witnesses to the
murders and they lacked forensic
evidence that juries sometimes look for
in this age of CSI like a victim's Blood
on the defendant's clothes prosecutors
guessed that the pair were killed at
around 9pm but they couldn't pinpoint a
time of death with certainty the alleged
motive could also have struck some
jurors as kind of weak
while murdering someone to cover up a
lesser crime is not unheard of killing
your own wife and son over some
Financial crimes
it could be a bridge too far and since
the prosecution claimed that Cousin
Eddie left drugs for Alex near the
kennels the defense speculated that
Eddie or Eddie's dealer friends may have
been the real culprits but these gaps in
the prosecution's case are to be
expected slam dunk prosecution cases
often don't go to trial and whatever
weaknesses the prosecution may have had
the defense had vastly more Alex said
all of his bad Deeds were caused by his
drug habit but maintaining his drug
habit and hiding his financial crimes
could have motivated him to violence
especially since he already admitted to
a suicide For Hire plot to funnel money
to a surviving son the beach family's
lawyer Chris Tinsley testified at trial
that he intended to sue Maggie and Alex
personally which could have resulted in
a huge verdict that would have destroyed
their wealth he gets up close in my face
and says hey Bo what's this I'm hearing
about what you're saying if you don't
think I can burn your house down I'm not
going to do everything you're wrong you
need to settle this case I took it is he
tried to intimidate me he didn't
intimidate me and and sort of bully me
into
backing off as for the weapons
prosecutors said casings for bullets
from a 300 Blackout rifle were found
near Maggie's body and the murdochs
owned a rifle chambered in 300 Blackout
and the weapon is now missing Alex also
couldn't account for the clothing he was
wearing on the day of the murders his
clothes have never been found his
mother's caregiver testified that after
the murders Alex tried to remind her
about what he was wearing he also tried
to convince her that she misremembered
the amount of time he spent with his
mother that night he said you remember
the shirt I was wearing that Vinnie Vine
shirt those were that's what he said to
me I don't remember that I don't
remember him wearing that shirt that day
Alex said he was there for about 50
minutes the caregiver told the police it
was 10 to 20. all told this is a case
where Alex Murdoch had to take the stand
Alex previously told police that he had
not been to the kennels before the
murders the prosecution was able to
prove through that Snapchat video that
he almost certainly was
under those circumstances Alex had to
explain the inconsistency himself his
defense attorney couldn't massage those
facts or explain them away Alex had to
do what plenty of defendants have tried
in the past I lied about this but I'm
telling the truth about that
by itself that's not impossible to do
the problem is it opened up everything
else all of Alex's Financial crimes and
the suicide for higher scheme and his
credibility was shot his testimony ended
up sounding like something else entirely
I lied about this and I'm lying about
that the speed of the jury's verdict
just three hours of deliberation after a
trial lasting a month and a half speaks
volumes the day after the verdict was
read Alex Murdoch was sentenced to two
consecutive life sentences for murdering
his wife and son
rightfully so yeah credibility in front
of a judge or jury is everything whether
you're a lawyer or a defendant your
credibility is often all you have and
once you lose it you never get it back
it's been fascinating to watch all the
crazy twists and turns in the Murdoch
case and one thing that has helped keep
track of everything is today's sponsor
morningbrew because that's my favorite
way to catch up with pop culture and the
news in fact they've been covering the
Murdoch trial for weeks now when I wake
up morning Brew is the first thing that
I read I've actually been subscribed to
morning Brew for forever it's one of my
absolute favorite newsletters and I'm
thrilled to tell you why because morning
Brew if you didn't already know is a
free daily newsletter delivered Monday
through Sunday and it gets you up to
speed on business finance Tech and law
in just five minutes and it provides a
fantastic quick summary of the most
important issues while being witty
irreverent and informative and did I
mention it's completely free this week I
learned all about chat gbt on college
campuses Amazon backing out of building
hq2 because you know they're firing lots
of people instead and Chris Rock's new
stand-up special it's basically exactly
the mix of news that I'm actually
interested in and the stuff that I
didn't even know I wanted to know about
and it's all written in a hilarious
style morning Brew is one of the few
emails that I actually open every single
day so Legal Eagles this one is a
complete no-brainer morning Brew is
completely free and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe just click on
the link that's on screen right now or
in the description to get morning Brew
for free and not only will you get a
newsletter that you'll actually read
you'll actually help out this channel
too so click on the link below to get
morning Brew right away and after that
click on this link over here for more
illegal eagle or I'll see you in court